what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we have really big
news in the thor universe today i say
that because we have news for thor love
and thunder but also news for his
brother loki season 2 for loki has
officially begun and they have
officially shared the first photo from
loki season 2 and it might not be
exactly what you think it looks like
they might be taking the story at least
in the beginning of season 2 in a
different direction than we all thought
then we have big news about thor love
and thunder the official run time some
new footage to go over and break down
and tickets are officially on sale right
now and ten new posters have been
released for thor love and thunder and
chris hemsworth has spoken out about
russell crowe's performance as zeus and
about christian bale's performance as
gore the godbutcher so a lot of really
exciting things in the norse god world
to go over today and a big thank you to
nordpass for sponsoring this video more
on them in just a bit so just a quick
recap at the end of loki season 1 sylvie
and loki finally came face to face with
the creator of the tva he who remains
who is a variant of nathaniel richards
aka
kang the conqueror and he pretty much
told loki and sylvie that if they killed
him then a bunch of different branch
timelines would be created from the
sacred timeline and his variants would
be let loose again and they would
basically cause another multiversal war
now sylvie was taken from her family at
a very very young age she spent her
whole life running away from the tva and
planning on how to take them down so at
the end of it all she decided to kill
kang the conqueror despite the
consequences and she ended up running
away from loki now loki was heartbroken
but he went back to the tva in search of
mobius in which when he finally found
mobius mobius did not know who he was
which of course was a huge surprise
seeing as how loki and mobius just
became pretty much best friends and they
worked together and loki helped him
realize that he was just another variant
he wasn't actually created by the tva
but had an actual life however mobius
seems to not remember any of this and
loki turns and he looks at a statue of
where the timekeepers used to be and
instead he sees a statue of kang it was
a pretty epic ending but a massive
cliffhanger but it looks like we kind of
know what's going to happen next thanks
to the first photo revealed from the set
of loki 2. now as you can see here loki
is back in the tva prison uniform and if
you look on his neck he looks like he
has another time collar on his neck the
one that allows the tva to basically
control him so it looks like loki is
going to be yet again a prisoner of the
tva since mobius doesn't know who he is
anymore and since hunter b15 doesn't
know who loki is either they are most
likely going to see him for what he is a
variant who has escaped so they're going
to put him in prison and most likely
questioned him since he showed up kind
of out of nowhere at the end where
everything was in chaos but keep in mind
sylvie is still out there she could be
the one who comes to rescue him plus
we're not exactly sure what is happening
at the end of loki season 1. we're not
sure if this is indeed the same mobius
and his mind has simply been reset or if
it's a completely different mobius
altogether so if that's the case our
mobius loki's mobius is still out there
and could potentially come and rescue
our loki but it looks like at least four
at the beginning of the series loki is
going to be a prisoner yet again of the
tva i can't wait to see what happens
with loki it's my favorite disney plus
show so far from marvel so hopefully we
find out a release date soon and now we
have some new footage from thor love and
thunder to go over and you can buy
tickets for thor love and thunder right
now so let's break down this new footage
and new character posters that we got
for the movie but first a big thank you
to nordpass for sponsoring this video
nordpass is here to make your life
easier and a little more stress-free
nordpas stores all of your passwords in
one place and not only that but it
generates secure passwords for you
checks the health of your current
existing passwords and it can save you
time by helping you log into websites
faster shop and browse faster because
you can securely store your passwords
and credit card information in nordpass
and it will autofill for you and it
stores your password securely nordpass
is a zero knowledge password manager
meaning they don't even know your
passwords inside the account they also
have a data breach scanner to find out
if any online account or any of your
card information has been leaked and
this is important because data leaks
happen all the time for example the
united states almost has 1.7 billion
data leaks with russia having a little
bit over 2.8 billion so to make life
easier and safer you can go to
nordpass.com
cosmic to get an exclusive discount off
of a two-year nordpass premium plan plus
you get an additional month for free so
use code cosmic or go to nordpass.com
cosmic
all right if you haven't seen the new
thor love and thunder footage here it is
there's a maniac who seeks to end us all
we must do something
i'm putting together the greatest he
ever called he's my best friend
valkyrie i get to fight again
the guardians give me those and jane the
old ex-girlfriend judy foster jane
foster
you are not like the other gods of kill
thor love and thunder pg-13 tickets on
sale now so tickets are on sale now for
thor love and thunder and if you live in
one of those places where you have to
buy tickets in advance to see it on the
first day i would buy them right now but
let's talk about the new footage that
was shown in the very beginning of this
new trailer we can see that thor is
talking to the people of asgard and he's
basically telling them that gore the god
butcher is coming for all of the
asgardians he's on a quest to kill all
of the gods out there so they must do
something about it now the thing to keep
in mind about the scene is one it looks
like they are about to leave we can
actually see jane foster on the boat
with thor and also keep in mind that
thor probably hasn't been around for
quite some time now remember he's been
off with the guardians of the galaxy
since avengers in-game so thor has
probably returned here for the first
time in a while and people are looking
to him as their former king to know what
to do about gore the god butcher it's
here where things are kind of misleading
for marvel studios thor says that he's
putting together his team and he starts
listing off different people and
different groups this is the misleading
part because the guardians are mentioned
in this scene and i don't think that
they are actually going to be helping
fight gore the god butcher yes the
guardians are going to be in this film
but i think they're only going to be in
the beginning of this movie as sad as
that is i would actually love to see the
guardians take on gore the god butcher
with thor jane foster korg valkyrie
everybody else i'd love to see a very
big fight but it's a thor movie not a
guardians movie and the guardians have
to get on to do their stuff to do
whatever is going to take place in
guardians vol 3. so this part can be a
little bit misleading he also mentions
valkyrie as one of the people in the
group but i actually think he's talking
to valkyrie here if you notice the
background of the room that thor and
cord are in it's actually the same
background of the room that valkyrie is
in where she's at the board table
talking to a bunch of different
political figures so my guess is that
thor and korg kind of go and find her
during this meeting to tell her that
gore the god butcher is coming for the
gods the asgardians and they have to put
a team together to go and fight him this
also leads me to believe that jane
foster's thor probably shows up pretty
early on in the movie because in the
scene where thor is telling the
asgardians that they have to do
something about gore the god butcher
jane foster is there and we know that
this is before they go to olympus and
i'm assuming they go to olympus probably
about two quarters into the movie so
jane probably comes in relatively early
so things are probably going to move
pretty quickly with this movie and we
did just find out that the official run
time for the movie is an hour and 59
minutes one of the shortest marvel films
that we've had in a while however i'm
not really that concerned thor ragnarok
wasn't that long either and i think that
it's one of the greatest marvel movies
ever and it's only 11 minutes longer
than this movie is going to be so i have
full faith in taikawatiti to make a
great movie even though it's not that
long plus like i mentioned in the
beginning the cast has done nothing but
praised christian bale's performance to
score the god butcher and russell
crowe's performance as zeus the cast
said that they were just blown away by
their performances so we have two
amazing seasoned veteran actors who
apparently have just knocked it out of
the ballpark with our returning cast and
crew for thor ragnarok who we love very
very much so i'm not really concerned
about this movie at all i think it's
going to be fantastic and just take a
look at some of these posters that have
been released for thor love and thunder
we have some imax posters we have some
dolby digital posters and some screen x
posters as well along with individual
character posters these all look amazing
and i also really love that tooth nasher
and tooth grinder have their own poster
as well hearing all of this news gets me
super excited about thor love and
thunder and these posters are amazing as
well and we're less than a month away
till the release of thor love and
thunder so let me know how excited you
are in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest marvel news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you